a graph is a nonlinear data structure
that contains nodes and edges a node or
vertex is just a single unique value
while an edge represents a connection or
relationship between two of these nodes
think of something like Instagram every
user is a node every time you follow a
user you create a new edge connecting
two nodes together this is known as a
directed graph because the relationship
flows one way the follower follows the
following and not vice-versa
now consider facebook your edges in the
graph are friendships this relationship
goes both ways which is known as an
undirected graph graphs can also be
weighted which means the node has some
additional data about the relationship
like the distance between two airports a
node might also point to itself like an
airplane that takes off and comes back
to land at the same airport this is
known as a cycle graphs are used in many
real-life software products and you'll
often be asked to represent a graphic
code in a technical interview one way to
represent a graph is with a 2d array or
adjacency matrix create one row and one
column for every node when two nodes
have an edge or connection add a one at
the point they intersect this makes it
fast and easy to look up a specific age
or to add a new edge but as a 2d array
it takes quadratic space complexity and
quadratic time to insert a new node into
the graph an alternative approach is an
adjacency list in this representation we
start with a collection of nodes then
each item has its own array of its
neighbors this makes it faster to
iterate over a nodes edges and is more
efficient with memory especially when
you have many nodes and few edges in
your interview you'll likely need to
traverse your graph one option is a
depth-first search start with any random
node go to its first child then its
first child and do that for as long as
you can when there are no more children
backtrack to the last node and continue
the process this algorithm is usually
implemented with a recursive function
another option is a breadth-first search
from your starting node add all of the
direct children to a queue once they've
been visited move on to the
grandchildren and continue following
this pattern and layers this has been
graphs in 100 seconds but hang out for a
few minutes because now we're going to
implement these algorithms in JavaScript
if you're new here like and subscribe
hit the like button open your IDE and
get ready to go beyond 100 seconds as a
developer you'll come across all kinds
of different real-life implementations
of graphs I mentioned Facebook social
graph at the beginning of the video and
they're commonly used for recommend
engines like Yelp for example to connect
businesses to users to reviews or
Netflix to connect the movies that you
watch two movies that you might want to
watch in the future they're also used to
represent Geographic data for example on
Google Maps you can think of every
intersection as a node and then every
Road and its distance as the edge
connecting these two nodes over the next
few minutes we'll implement a basic
graph in JavaScript based on the flight
connections between airports in this
case every airport is a node and the
edge represents whether or not you can
fly from one Airport to another this
edge could contain additional
information like the kilometers between
the two airports in which case that
would give us a weighted graph the
routes between two airports could be
one-way or two-way when they go one way
we have a directed graph if they go both
ways
it's an undirected graph for this demo
we'll try to keep things simple we'll
make an undirected graph assuming that
when an airplane has a route it can fly
back and forth between the two airports
it'll be unweighted so the routes
between the two airports won't carry any
additional data and we'll assume cycles
are not possible the first thing we'll
need to do is represent our graphing
code most programming interviews will
have you write code in whatever language
you prefer we'll be using Java Script
here but the most important tip I can
give you is to simply explain your
thinking process as you're writing your
code most technical interviewers are
trying to get some insight into your
thinking process and care less if you
write perfectly formatted code let's go
ahead and walk through a few examples
you might get a question like this
here's a list of airports and it was two
routes connecting these airports now
represent this data as a graph so given
this data we can represent the graph in
two ways a matrix or an adjacency list a
matrix takes up more space but is
generally easier to visualize and
represent because it's just a
two-dimensional array filled with ones
and zeros now looking at this data I can
see there are not very many routes
relative to the number of possible
combinations between these airports that
means our matrix would be very sparse or
in other words filled with a bunch of
zeros and take up a lot of unnecessary
space and it would be less efficient to
iterate over and search through
therefore I choose to represent my graph
as an adjacency list we can implement an
adjacency list as a set of key value
pairs where the key is the name of the
airport or the node and the value is an
array of edges or the other airports
that it's connected to we could
implement this with a regular JavaScript
object
but a better option might be a map when
you're doing algorithm problems in
JavaScript a map tends to be a better
option than a regular object it has some
additional API methods that can be
useful for problems like this and it
just behaves more like a regular
dictionary or hash map that you'll find
in other languages so the map is our
graph and at this point it's empty the
first thing we'll do is define a
function that can add a node to the map
this function takes the airport code as
its argument and then calls adjacency
list set on the airport and starts it
off with an empty array and that's all
it takes to represent a node on the
graph to add an edge we need to update
the entries for both the origin Airport
and the destination first we'll grab the
entry for the origin Airport and then
push the destination onto its list and
then we'll do the inverse of that by
getting the destination and then pushing
the origin onto its list and that's our
entire API for building a graph as an
adjacency list the next step is to use
this API with our source data we can
loop over the airport's with for each
and for each one call the add node
method to add a node to the graph once
we have our nodes we can then loop over
the routes and add an edge for each
route in that array that function takes
two arguments so I'm going to use the
rest syntax here 2d structure them now
you can go ahead and console.log this
graph by running it and ojs and you
should get an output that looks similar
to this congratulations you just got
through the first part of the interview
but that was the easy part
now the interviewer wants you to
implement an algorithm to figure out if
there's a route between Phoenix and
Bangkok and as you know from earlier in
the video there are two main ways we can
approach this depth-first search or
breadth-first search i think the easier
one to understand is BFS you know in
order to search a graph you have to
start somewhere
in this case we'll start with the
phoenix node so we need a function that
takes a starting node as its argument
write that out on the whiteboard or as
pseudocode in whatever editing toy
you're using for the interview from the
starting node you want to visit all the
children and see if any of them are
bankok if not you'll want to visit their
children and do the same thing and then
you'll continue doing this in layers
until you find the airport you're
looking for we can represent this
process as a queue which in JavaScript
is just an array where the first item in
is the first item out and of course the
first item in your queue should be the
starting node now while the queue has
items in it or the length is greater
than 0 we'll grab the first item in the
array using the
Raye shift method this method will
mutate the original array by removing
the first item in it and then return
that item to us here that we set as the
airport variable our next step is to
grab all the edges for this node in the
graph we can do that by calling
adjacency lists to get with that airport
name as the key that'll give us all the
destinations for the airport where it's
children so we can loop over them and
add them to the queue as well we can
also go ahead and log out if any of
these airports are Bangkok the airport
we're looking for now one major problem
with this code at the moment is that
airports have many interconnected routes
and that means our algorithm will be
visiting the same nodes over and over
again and in our case this creates an
infinite loop because the queue is never
emptied we can avoid that by keeping
track of the airports that we visited in
the past an easy way to do that in
JavaScript is with a set which is
basically an array but all the values in
it are unique we set it up as an empty
set when the function is first called
then we can use it to set up some
conditional logic in our loop we will
only in queue an item if it does not
have this destination a set has a has
method where you can pass a value to see
if it exists currently in the set and
then we'll mark the destination as
visited by adding it to the set then
we'll move the line of code that adds
this item to the queue inside of our
condition here so an item only gets in
queued if it has not been visited
already now let's go ahead and call our
function using Phoenix as the starting
node what you'll notice is that it goes
through nine airports before it finally
finds Bangkok it starts with all the
connections to Phoenix then all the
connections to JFK then from Mexico City
it finds a route to Bangkok and then it
also finds a second route through Lima
Peru so breadth-first search would be
really good for finding all the possible
routes to determine which one is the
most efficient at this point your
interviewer is super impressed but then
he or she says our only concern is if a
route from Phoenix to Bangkok exists we
don't care if there are multiple routes
we don't care if it's the best route we
just want to find a route as quickly as
possible
how can you traverse this graph more
efficiently to meet that need an
approach that would be more efficient
for this particular requirement is a
depth-first search instead of going
through all the children or destinations
for each Airport will go to its first
child and then to its first child and
its first child and so on until we hit
Bangkok and if we don't find it will
backtrack to the top of the graph and
follow the same pattern in the last
example we used a queue but in this
example we're
- use a recursive function or in other
words a function that calls itself until
it reaches some kind of stopping point
this function will take a starting node
as its first argument and then a set as
a second argument that keeps track of
the different cities that we visited
because again we don't want to visit the
same node more than once from there
we'll grab the edges or destinations
from our adjacency list we'll loop over
them just like we did before and when we
find what we're looking for we'll just
return from the function now here's the
interesting part if a node has not been
visited then we'll go ahead and call the
same function or in other words call it
recursively with the current destination
and the loop as well as our visited set
that means this function call will be
pushed to the top of the call stack
making the algorithm go deeper and
deeper into the tree until it reaches a
stopping point and that means this
function will continue calling itself
recursively until all the airports have
been visited or until it finds Bangkok
in this example it only takes three
steps or three function calls to find
the route as opposed to eight in our
previous algorithm but the interviewer
has one last question what is the time
complexity of the algorithm that you
just implemented as expressed in Big O
notation for both breadth-first and
depth-first search Big O is expressed as
V Plus E which is the total number of
nodes or vertices plus the number of
edges or in other words the time
performance of the algorithm will scale
linear based on the number of nodes and
edges that are added to the graph I'm
gonna go ahead and wrap things up there
but there are many other algorithms you
can use to traverse a graph so if you
want to see more videos like this let me
know in the comments thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next
[Music]